one thing i want to say before i
continue if someone tell you that their
luck is nothing important it is
important
romalias thank you so much for taking
the time to be on the show
sure uh my my pleasure thank you uh
michael for hosting me really appreciate
it i just want i just want to make i
just want to mention ron before we start
that you know we had a session a few
hours ago that we were about to start
and you were coming out of the hospital
with a mask and you were telling me that
you're working on on some on some
different
uh you know different studies in regards
to covet and i just got so much
inspiration from that and i was so happy
that we're delaying talk
because you're doing such important work
in the in biomedical so first of all
thank you
for all the amazing work that you're
doing and now please yes tell me a
little bit about yourself
sure i would be more than happy to so um
basically i was born and raised in
israel uh in a
in basically one of the four big
cities in israel but is actually the
what's called percheva which is
basically the gecko wing of the desert
or the capital
so it's kind of a diamond it's high five
on the north
is there tel aviv jerusalem and then
in the south but it's it's david ben
gurion's favorite city so that's what
counts
that's true but he went to south and he
went to uh that's true
okay yes um long story short i learned
chemical engineering and biotechnology
uh in bengal university environment
institute i did my
a bachelor degree and then my
phd in both universities and while i was
in
my phd i came across
a few patterns that we developed and
then
i thought that we were going to maybe
start a new as a startup company
around our patents so i actually went to
uh i decided that i want to be
kind of a gay executive or maybe the ceo
of the company
so i decided that i need to learn
mba so i went to an mba program that was
a boston program it was an mba get uh
started with the professors from harvard
university in boston universities
in israel wow um during my
last year of my phd which was my second
year of my mba
my professor benguyon decided to go and
start a company
in mit with a bob lanker it's a huge
name in the field of drug delivery and
medical devices
so i wrote a letter to the dean of
harvard
and said that if it's a true boston
program i would like to do
my second year in boston while i'm
actually writing my phd
in mit and guess what happened i moved
to a
about for a year i wrote my phd during
the day
in mit and i went to school and gaming
in
harvard big school and
i guess with my first experience with
the us i
then graduated and went to do my post
work in
ucsf in university of california san
francisco
once i was there i learned
i actually enjoyed myself in a
basketball game
and long story short i was in bed and on
my second week
of my postdoc in bed for six weeks
basically cannot move anywhere and then
what did you do you're playing
basketball how do you get how do you go
to bed for six weeks
oh because i i got my acl torn apart and
in my minister
i went to play basketball and then i was
injured
and then i needed to have a surgery
and while i was waiting for the surgery
and then for the recovery
i basically wrote a grant for the nih i
got to 5 million dollars
we wrote a few papers and cancer
research about it
i came with a grant from the cancer
with roberto tobacco research in the
ucsf
and from watching the uh
award of scholarship so it was another
one
and then they actually i won five
million dollar grant
which was a lot of money again and it's
a lot of money now too
yeah i i i wrote a few people in cancer
research
and a year later i got a
assistant professor in ucsf so i was a
super professor
in ucsf and uc berkeley for gene therapy
drug delivery and biomedical engineering
you basically see all these
entrepreneurs and i ate my mba and i
knew
that what i really want to do is to
start my own company
and really help humanity with some
new uh invention and new things that we
did
so i i was lucky enough to actually have
a few patterns in my phd thesis
but also with my postdoc so i was
working on tissue engineering
right and i then worked on there with
some medical devices
and drug testing so we wrote a few more
patterns we wrote
a few more papers we tried to start a
new
a new company but uh again was a
ask after they're actually giving a
lecture in london
to join a company called alza anza was a
company
in the silicon valley by get started by
alfred the time uh
it was 3 000 people uh i joined the
they actually asked me to join around
1999.
there was the y2k long story short and
joined them a year later
uh actually a year and a half later in
and then um the company
was acquired a half a year later by
johnson and johnson
so in my first my first exit
i basically was a lucky i was in the
right place
in the right place at the right time and
once a
aza was acquired for a 12.3 billion
dollars
i all the all the management went to
start a giant pharmaceutical
so i was lucky enough to be in there on
the side
to basically go to the management of the
whole portfolio of joint delivery of
johnson
yeah i was johnson something for about
three three years
um one thing i want to say before i
continue
if someone tell you that luck is not
important it is important
excuse me wrong as much as and the
better luck is always better than any
any other
clinic rom i think you can definitely
say that luck is important but at the
end
you're all up until this point where
you're saying that luck is important
you've already managed to do your phd on
uh by
on biotech you've already done your um
you've already done your mba through
harvard
so let's just say that yes luck may be
important but in your case i think your
your record speaks for yourself in terms
of your professionalism
if you are working hard and you're
trying to go to the right places can
actually go with you so
it's a game of the game if you are
really doing what you need
and even even if you fail eventually
things will
go with you um anyway i was at anza i
was there for about four years after
four years they wanted me to move to a
new brunswick in
the east coast i didn't want to move so
actually
to join a small company i was employing
number five in a small company called
enough neuroscience a company that was
started in palo alto
was doing um was basically was a
spin-off from genetics
when genetically wanted uh to go only
into oncology
testing out all the neurodegenerative
diseases
i know arnold rosenthal who was the head
of a knowledge generating business
at germany i started this company
contribute to neuroscience
today uh all you guys living in
west coast can know there is a building
of
pfizer called enough in
south san francisco that was where the
original rematch was
rinak was acquired by pfizer two and a
half years later
for like 500 million dollars and we had
one antibody for
a handful we have one antibody for
repair
and we have one antibody for a for a
migraine which is called the antecedent
all of these
except of the alzheimer's are basically
drugs one is a drug by pfizer for pain
the other one is a joint painkiller
for a migraine uh i have to stop you
here and because i have to i have to
understand
what i mean what is the commonality
between all these things that you've
worked on i mean
it sounds like all of them are are very
very meaningful they improve the lives
of many they're very
they're very uh you know challenging
professionally because you're actually
inventing new drugs you're inventing new
treatments
for a lot of these i mean just as a as
when you were assistant professor you
wrote over
40 publication you co-authored for over
40 publications
where does this curiosity come from and
this motivation to build businesses or
to help run businesses
while at the same time helping you know
millions of people around the world with
your inventions
i think it's coming from from you to you
know what you know what you were doing
i was um you know i had left product
i i was a child that i was dealing with
with doctors all my life but because i
was treated by them
um i was fascinated by the this
i wanted to be a doctor in israel you
have to go to the army
i couldn't go to the army to i wanted to
be a doctor the army wanted me to go and
learn physics and on computers
i say that i don't want to they actually
gave me my own
my own program at the time uh it was a
program called tag prior i didn't want
to go there they gave me a special one
um but at the end of the day i think
it's really coming from the
from where i i felt like all my life i
really wanted to help
uh to help society and to help people i
really wanted to be doctor all my life
all
and by owning a violin player
when i was 17 years old i actually
accepted to junior but
i decided i'm not going to okay wrong
vegas
hold on i have to breathe
one second first of all my brother went
to yeah that's exactly what i'm feeling
right now my brother went to juilliard
and
so it's very close to heart and i just
want to recap
the army wants you to wants you to go to
talpiyot you're probably the first
person in the history
of the nation of israel that declines
that that offer and
so that they give you your own program
you get accepted to juilliard
which and any anybody oh everybody knows
this is like the most prestigious school
in the world for music i saw my brother
you know with blood sweat and tears all
his life until he got accepted there and
and had a phenomenal experience in the
university
you don't go to juilliard right because
you're not a violinist now you're
you're you're a venture capital in
environment so you you forgo juilliard
i'm still i'm scared playing the violin
and i still have my own two cds and i'm
still playing today and playing with
friends
so i am
you don't have to do it as a profession
so you just so you don't go to juilliard
uh but but you could but you continue
and you know i can't believe
i i i'm already sad that we only have a
few minutes left but rome i have to get
your perspective today
you're in venture capital you're
investing as a part of
so many different funds one of them j
ventures which we're both a part of
but what i mean what is it about this
biomedical field that really intrigues
you that and where are we headed now so
i mean
as a young entrepreneur i want to learn
what should what
what are the most exciting things in the
field and where can i put my
you know my time and effort into helping
others
i think that one of the most important
things in general
not only in medicine and medical but in
anything in life is that if you attack a
problem you need to attack it from
different angles and that's exactly
where the field of
medical the medical field is going now
if you can if you think about the
collaboration now between the high-tech
and your biotech you can see that
basically now with
all the ai and machine learning and all
the digital health
you can basically get so many data
that you were unable to collect in
the past um in a in a big data
and basically analyze it not only from
the perspective of
of only a biology or how are you looking
into a
into antibodies or drugs but then you
also can see how the effect
and what is the and basically is
a combination of bioinformatics that was
known in the past
now with the big data and look at today
the collaboration between all these
films
the big data the ai the machine learning
all the data and
knowledge that we have formed from the
medical field this is where the
the world is going um it's still going
to be at the end of the day
you still will need to go back to their
old biology
and find the new targets and your new
therapies
for every drug but the weather might be
much much shorter
uh you can be much more accurate and
basically the world is going towards
personalized medicine so it's not going
to be any more
kind of capsules or pills or anything
that you are thinking not even
antibodies
that are good for let's say about 25
or 2 percent of the society each person
is going to have kind of a gene editing
or dna
analysis and by knowing that knowing
exactly what are the
expression of genes and the receptors
that you have you would know exactly
how to target and eventually i'm pretty
much sure that is going to be like a
collaboration of men's
of nano nano particles uh you know
the the great isa casimo which is a
basically when you have a little
submarine that's going into the
uh going into the
and can actually go through your body
and
really see what are the problem and
solve it get something where the field
is going
everything is going to be targeted it's
going to be collaboration with being
between engineering
uh biology and basically
rom i think that i think this is just
inspiring what what
what made you do the transition from an
entrepreneur and tech executive
to venture capital and and how how much
time are you spending on on either
aspects of your professional career now
are you mostly focusing on one of them
or is it always a balancing between the
two
i think there's always a balancing you
know it's really important to understand
you know when you're investing in this
biotech field you really understand to
understand you really need to understand
what is your feeling you need to
understand how time things are taken
again of the day is always people and is
always technologies and again people and
people people
but you need to understand this
technology because you need to know how
to make the right investment
and then at the end of the year you
invest in people and
you need people that know how to solve
a situation we have to talk their
difficult situation
have to stop crisis because in every
startup
we can see a great business plan like
again okay
nothing is close to the business plan
it's going completely to a different way
that's why the people is the most
important thing in everything
and uh and again if you have good people
and you have
the right collection of people from
different fields
you always will be able to do all this
stuff but i'm also assuming that
i'm also assuming that in the in the
companies that you invest in
in the medical space and they're not
they're not the average you know silicon
valley company that's another
you know another social media app or
another consumer product this is more
long-term research that the research is
is the business right the ip of the
company and the knowledge
i mean if it either works and then it's
hugely successful or it doesn't work
and then it dies down is that is that
the right comparison definitely i'm we
are always looking for the cutting-edge
technology for always for the next thing
for something that is unknown for
something that is the next thing because
this is the field if you want to invest
and you can
do that you can be a generic you can be
me too you can you know a lot of things
but
if you want to win to be a lean
entrepreneur and you really want to take
the risk
you really need to invest in the
cutting-edge technology
and taking the risk in life you need to
know that sometimes you are
taking the wrong curve or you are taking
the gamble on the wrong application but
then at the end of the day
if you are looking on a variety and a
nice portfolio of situations
again again uh you probably will uh
hopefully
will be able to target it or
to to be the winner of at least one or
two you need only one
game and you need only one facebook you
need
only one current format and then again
if you are
able to to get this one then you will
have enough
funds to actually invest in other very
interesting cutting edge
at the end of the day you never know
even if any
technology at the end of the day can
become uh
merged to another technology and it
happens it's something that we went from
one technology he didn't work but when
we merged it with others
and gang of games maybe even five years
later or maybe even ten years later
because the market wasn't wasn't ready
so or the technology wasn't there yet it
still
can the dreams continue and become true
okay so question for myself
i'm i'm an engineer i'm studying
artificial intelligence at university
now
but i definitely want to see myself
being an active part
in the space that you're in right now
because i mean that's where that's where
the future is and this is what is
actually going to
to to either save or at least magnify
and help
the lives of millions of people if not
billions of people around the world
if i want to be an entrepreneur in your
space
and i have the expertise in in computer
science and machine learning do i also
need
to go and pursue academics in in in in
biology or biotech or is it enough that
i find the right partners
who can complement my knowledge with
their knowledge
and and go that so i'm this is a serious
question that i'm i'm wondering
what what's the right path for me you
know
what i'm saying no you don't need to be
uh you don't need to be all of them
from my perspective i always like to
know a lot of things
so you don't need to go to be to have
like a green biology or something
you definitely need to work with right
people but right if you ask me
you i will definitely recommend that you
would take some
advanced curses or we will take some
classes or something
in the field you will always try to
learn more and more
you know it's um if you have an ending
uh process like uh
four games longer is a i'm i i have made
the
in a black belt uh martial arts and
basically you are saying
never ending excellence like
you you never can stay in your comfort
zone
always you need to get to improve
yourself to get
better to know better uh once you try to
over achieve index and really try to go
out of your comfort zone and all the
time then and then and then
eventually you will get the right people
around you you will find the right
people but again
you need to know one thing really really
well if you are really doing your
ai and machine learning be you know
excelling
being the expert in it so be gay be
the point of a
of excellence from ai in your team
but definitely try to uh surround
yourself with the team of people coming
for me
for maybe biotech especially if you want
to go into buying
and then when once you decide to do
something in the field
definitely try and learn about it you
don't need to be the expert you
don't need to be the best person in the
room
in the field but definitely try to
understand what they are talking about
so you know
what's going on around you rome i am so
inspired by this talk thank you again
for giving me your time right before we
leave i need three words that you would
use to describe yourself
definitely motivation
[Music]
improvement what is the second one you
have an engine
improvement never-ending improvement
um you know never stop the dream always
dream
and once you dream a dream try to
achieve it and
make it coming true rome thank you for
saving lives thank you for making the
world better that's that's all i have to
say
and and i'm definitely going to keep you
to keep in the loop and i'm thankful for
this
friendship and relationship and i'm
going to come back for more and
more and more advice over the years so
thank you
welcome i'm happy thank you michael
thank you take care
bye bye